joining me today is a biologist a former
professor at Evergreen State who is now
a professor in exile brett weinstein
welcome back to the rubin report thanks
for having me back on professor in exile
my friend that's what it says on your
Twitter bio which means it's your most
defining characteristic right now that
has become the tenor of my life all
right so I went into the Reuben report
archives they're very much like the Jedi
archives I went into the Reuben record
archives
this morning the you were on this show
originally on may 30th 2017 so that's
about a year and a half ago it was just
as the Evergreen brouhaha was beginning
you you still were employed at the time
which probably seems like a lifetime ago
so I think first maybe we should just
play a little catch-up from then now
just to be clear you you have been on
the show one since then you were on with
your brother Eric and we did a little
bit about Evergreen in your life but I
saw I thought first let's just do catch
up on on what happened where you're at
where you're going and then we're gonna
do sort of new territory and we're gonna
cover a lot of biology and all that
great so May 30th of 2017 would be
exactly one week into the riots the
protest at my classroom that became
relatively famous happened on May 23rd
so one weekend I was sitting in this
chair and that feels like a lifetime ago
does it I mean it was like it for me and
I think less has happened to me although
it's been pretty busy here and have the
transformation of my life and Heather's
life in that period has been so dramatic
that it's hard to even relate you know
I've never had so much happen in a year
yeah so okay so for people that don't
know anything about the story and I
suspect there's very few watching this
at the moment can you give me like the
92nd recap of what happened so can that
be done in 90 seconds let's say it can
be done with with carnage yeah say I
feared this question more than any other
because there's so much detail in the
story it can't be covered properly
alright give a give a Cliff Notes
version that basically
and an explainer equity and inclusion
movement got started on my campus as it
is on virtually every campus and the new
president of Evergreen through fuel on
the fire
he used the division over that issue to
accomplish things he could not have
accomplished otherwise I tried to block
his moves to dismantle the excellent
part of evergreens teaching model which
Heather and I were using to full effect
and I became effectively enemy number
one of this equity and inclusion
movement they arranged a protest at my
classroom very dramatic fifty students
showed up demanding my resignation not a
single one of them was a student I had
ever encountered but in any case they've
made a terrible error they filmed their
confrontation with me they uploaded it I
now know to Facebook somebody else in
the public picked those videos up and
broadcast them and the world watched me
tried to reason with them and that set
things in motion we're Evergreen started
using me as an excuse for its problems
it blamed me for what happened there for
the drop-off and enrollment for all
sorts of things and I started engaging
with the public about what was taking
place at Evergreen about issues of
freedom of expression free inquiry on
college campuses and increasingly
evolutionary biology which you know
people did not initially really
understand that that was the focus that
I had not freedom of speech issues yeah
now increasingly that's what people want
to talk to me about right although we're
gonna get to plenty of that because I
know that's what your your real focus
and passion is and it's sort of funny
that now you've been thrust into this
but in effect you were protesting
putting racist policies on campus is
that fair to say yes and this is one of
the I think hardest lessons for people
to learn people good people
get the idea that you can spot the right
side by certain heuristics and you know
there's been a historical fact of
oppressed people tending to be people of
color etc and so people have gotten lazy
about recognizing who's in the right if
you follow a principle to its logical
conclusions in other words if you're
against segregation for example as I am
then when the segregationists are
telling white people to leave campus or
asking them to leave campus then you are
committed to standing against
segregation and when you do stand
against segregation the world goes crazy
because people who are being lazy about
recognizing which side is defending the
principle that they they subscribe to
they fall out in the wrong place and so
anyway yes it is your principles and
adherence to them that gets you in
trouble yeah ok so you then show up in
this studio a week after this whole
thing goes down it was your first public
interview about any of this what did you
think at the time was going to happen by
talking about this publicly or what was
your hope at least by talking about this
publicly well you know initially my hope
was to expose the foolishness at
Evergreen and save the College from its
own worst instincts because your
audience may not care terribly deeply
about this but for a small number of
people for 4,000 students at a time
Evergreen was actually a wonderful
experiment in which it was possible for
people who haven't had tremendous
educational advantages before they got
to college to have an experience that
couldn't be reproduced anywhere else
evergreens model was so unique that if
you ended up in the right classrooms
with professors who really cared it was
it was like no other place and and you
were given incredible freedom as a
professor to do what you wanted with
these kids right I believe that the
position
Heather and I had was the freest
academic position in the country and
maybe on earth Wow
I mean really more freedom than a
tenured professor at Harvard has and
that was let's be honest it was both a
blessing and a curse if you decided to
use that freedom for good if you decided
to figure out how to innovate structures
that didn't exist anywhere else you
could do it and nobody could tell you
not to on the other hand if you decided
to you know take the rest of your career
off and you know teach with one hand
while you you know dealt with your
hobbies you could also get away with
murder and so that happened as well and
you know there was attention every every
good professor at Evergreen grumbles
about the fact that there are a large
number of people who are holding
positions there that they don't really
value and you know that the phrase that
we've that we typically used in private
on the faculty was that evergreen paid
in freedom which meant that it didn't
pay well it wasn't a good paying job but
the ability to have a blank canvas and
decide how you were you know what you
want to teach and in what way and to
innovate new mechanisms and take
students off campus for a week or two or
ten that freedom was a very valuable
commodity that Evergreen undervalued the
whole time it should have it should have
leveled with people that it was hiring
and it should have said look this job is
not going to make you wealthy but it can
make you very happy if you have the
temperament that really wants to figure
out what's possible so as this was
unfolding and now you went public and
you also did rogen and you were on
Tucker Carlson where you said I'm deeply
progressive because suddenly you were
sort of getting crap from you know your
side so to speak and you were getting
embraced by perhaps a different side and
I do want to get a little more into that
now because it shows what a sort of
crazy realignment politically we've had
these days were you shocked how deep it
went so you went public
you were you were giving the facts you
were exposing sort of the corruption and
how it went all the way up to the
administration and all that I think from
that first interview we did I think you
thought that there would be a course
correction in here
there was a chance for a course
correction and at least the way I read
the last year at no point was there even
a slowdown or any reflection from the
administration and the rest of it they
they just went in on this I am
completely shocked
yeah by the fact that the world's
recognition of just how off things were
at Evergreen did not force an
acknowledgment that something was wrong
so I would not have been surprised if
Evergreen had backed off cynically if
they had privately said actually we were
on the right track
we were Mis portrayed and but we
nonetheless have to acknowledge what the
world is saying to us the fact that that
did not happen at all still shocks me
and I can't explain it
because you have a president who is
widely understood to be is there a
polite word for bonkers like bananas -
but bonkers you know wackadoodle - yeah
but in any case we have a president who
was I mean look he's the Mad King right
he's the Mad King and you've got a whole
bunch of people standing around
accepting his authority when in fact
he's an outsider his understanding of
the college or his plans for the college
are completely inconsistent with the
values that the college was founded on
yeah and were they really accepting is
fre actually because there are moments
in the chaos of this that these videos
are opposed to where he can't even leave
to go to the bathroom and it's like he
was also a hostage in this in his own
maybe his own like perverted dream or
something you know I mean he was both
puppet and puppet here yeah okay and so
the thing is yes he is held hostage in
those things but I believe he's a
willing hostage in the sense that he's
trying to accomplish something and you
know look it tells the whole tale once
you say what we are doing is about
equity there is a whole swath of people
that cannot figure out how they would
object no matter what it is that you say
next no matter what your plan is
if you've said that it is for the
purpose
of racial equity then a whole section of
the population will just fall in
lockstep what is that what is that
psychologically do you think oh I know
because I think we're seeing this
everywhere now this is not just
something that's happening at
universities anymore this is happening
all over society I wish I could say that
it is an error in cognition that people
are seeing it incorrectly what I know
for sure now as well as anybody on earth
is that the part of people's minds that
drives them in the direction of silence
of self-editing of all of these things
is actually accurately perceiving a
threat that it cannot manage now I'm not
looking for sympathy I do not have my
job anymore and I miss it it was a great
job however I've landed on my feet and I
wouldn't trade my position for any other
I like where I am however first of all
there's not an infinite number of those
positions in the world so most people
who are looking at some sort of an
equity and inclusion juggernaut who are
thinking should I stand up actually have
to ask themselves what happens if I do
do I have an economic plan B for my
family right anybody who doesn't have an
economic plan B for their family and I
have to say as much as I would like
Evergreen to be a place in which all the
faculty had enough skills that they
could go do something else that they
have to they don't write they can't
easily move to another College because
the way they teach at Evergreen doesn't
create a CV that will get you hired
elsewhere easily and so I think lots of
people are looking ahead and saying if I
stand up and I say the right thing now
what what what will become of me and the
problem the place where I you know I
have sympathy for anybody who sees that
and I don't have a plan B I don't know
what to do where I lose sympathy with
them is when they then having made that
calculation rationalize what they are
saying when they join not reluctantly
but they become enthusiastic
allies of this movement in order to
basically they sell the rest of us out
right and in a weird way they almost
have to do that psychologically to live
with themselves right I mean otherwise
you realize that I mean then you are a
sellout in the you know it it's harsh
but it's true but what I'm so fat why
the reason I'm so fascinated with this
is because as you know I've been on tour
with Peterson for the last couple months
and I think this is the number one
question that we get asked people want
to speak up and they are afraid of
losing their jobs and and I think that's
why your story resonated with so many
people because people were looking at
you and going well it's pretty freakin
obvious this guy's not a racist he's not
a hater
he's a self-identified lefty and
progressive and all of these things and
somehow he stood up to the monster and I
think the fact that you're still here
and you're a cure not employed at the
moment and I do want to discuss that a
little bit too but the fact that you're
still here you're alive you're still
willing to talk about these things I
think that's the type of courage that
people are looking for at the moment
well you know I do so I have to say for
I don't know a year now I have had these
interactions you know a couple times a
day somebody will come up to me on the
street and unless I'm in Olympia it's
always nice right people have people say
even sans beard they're still coming up
actually that has reduced it I think I'm
not quite sure yeah there is that who I
think it is or is that erika sifrit I
don't know but you go buzz cut and then
you're scot-free Ben oh man Ivey yeah I
could go on the lam they'd never find me
yeah but the thing is the it raises
questions the stuff that people say to
me about what they see on the outside
you know I get to compare that to what
the experience was on the inside and so
I've done a lot of thinking about what
it is is you know is there some reason
that that I stood up when others didn't
and I think you know it comes down to
something simple which you know I'll
just I'll just put it out there I think
people are rationalizing their
acceptance of this nonsense movement in
order to sleep
mm-hmm and for some reason that
particular switch works the opposite way
from me if I heard myself rationalizing
that I would not be able to sleep so in
order to sleep I had to stand up and you
know I'm lucky I have really good
friends I have a wonderful brother who
was you know friends with you and that
put us in contact and I have something
else to talk about
you know evolutionary biology is
fascinating to people they don't know
how to think about it and they're you
know just as my students were they're
very interested to hear what I have to
say on the subject so that means somehow
even though I couldn't see it exactly on
May 23rd of 2017 there was a path
forward for me which you know it could
come crashing down tomorrow but so far
it looks good and I I regret nothing
is there an evolutionary explanation to
that type of person that either can
sleep or cannot sleep because you know
people come up to all of us all the time
now and they say I wish I could speak up
I don't want to lose my job my wife's
pissed at me I mean all of these things
and they're literally sometimes I'm
talking to people one on one in there
whispering I mean this this this layer
of fear is seriously real and it is
sitting on top of people so is there an
evolutionary explanation why at the
moment it seems that a very small amount
of people are doing it absolutely and
for me just quickly I would just say for
me it's like I don't know if it's about
sleeping I just I just feel like I'm
doing what's right that's it it's
actually not more you know it's not more
confusing or needs more of an
explanation than that that's just what
I'm doing yeah there are two things to
say on this front one so I know we're
going to talk more about evolutionary
theory later on but yeah there is a way
in which evolutionary theory stalled 30
years ago and I don't believe that the
explanation that you're looking for is
on the table in the way that you know
any evolutionist
you ask and say oh yeah the explanation
is over here but I do believe we can see
what it is there are a lot of
adaptations that do not map well onto
the individual if you look at the
individual and you say well why would
the person behave this way it seems
paradoxical sometimes if you look at
something larger than the individual and
it's not the group this is the thing
you've been caught in this argument
about group selection since the 60s and
or actually even earlier but that's
where it began to come to a head if you
look at the lineage that is to say a
population of people who are related now
talking about ancestral ancestral
populations there are many
characteristics that have value for the
lineage moving forward that are hard to
understand from the point of view of the
individual many of the things that we
have a really hard time explaining
including things like homosexuality and
religion many of these things are
adaptations that exist at that slightly
higher level and so what I would say is
an individual who can't sleep if they're
not doing the right thing or if they
hear themselves rationalizing that
individual is not well-suited to certain
jobs but they're very well suited to
other jobs and the idea that a
population has an emergent nature and
that you know a division of labor
between you know I'm not telling you
that not rationalising is the way we
should all be they may well be that we
need certain people who are very good at
carefully rationalizing certain things
in order to get jobs done I mean I would
imagine if you are in the military if
you were in a position of command in the
military that there are certain things
that you have to rationalize in order to
win the war now I'm not saying I don't
like war I'm not saying that you know
every war should be won you know you
should you should enter into a war that
isn't justified but once you've entered
into it that the goal is justified maybe
you have to rationalize
certain things you know you move troops
over here in order to protect something
over there well what are you doing to
these people you may be sending them to
their deaths so you know even talking
about it makes it makes me uncomfortable
because it's not something I would be
good at but the point is when you look
at the population and the fact is the
populations that we have alive on earth
today are all winners right these are
the winners irrespective of how you got
here irrespective of how oppressed your
population looks in relation to others
somehow you made it to the present
you're a winner those winning
populations had many characteristics
within them and they knew how to call
upon these people and you know sideline
those people and then switch it up at
the point you arrive somewhere else
where different skills are necessary so
in essence yeah I think there's a very
simple evolutionary explanation and some
of us have certain skills other people
have other skills and the real trick is
can you figure out the switching
mechanism that decides what to call on
at what moment that seems to be the key
part of this right I mean that's it it's
like some people are gonna do it some
people some people know they should do
it and won't do it some people probably
shouldn't do it and do do it and and
everything in between well you know I
you probably have this experience too
but when I when people come up to me and
they talk to me there's just a couple
different styles of conversation that
unfold you know there's lots of people
who want to you know apologize for what
happened to me which I always find a odd
you know unless they were there in the
room right unless it was them but I'm
guessing those people have not even ever
contact me but you know some people want
to apologize some people you know want
to thank me and some people there's this
one thread which is I'm facing something
like this - yeah can you give me some
advice and you know I always say the
same sort of thing to them and it throws
them you know I always say look it's not
safe you have to think very carefully
about what you're doing and don't kid
yourself about what you're signing up
for and you know you can look you just
watch in their eyes as they
grapple with the fact that they didn't
get what they wanted for me what they
wanted to be told they wanted somebody
to egg them on and then say do it it's
the right thing it'll work out and you
tell them oh it may not work out and you
know there's a moment of heartbreak but
my hope is that the people who should do
it have to go through that little
heartbreak in order to get to the other
side and so I among my various jobs at
the moment is to show people the abyss
yeah just say look is this the abyss you
want to jump if it is nobody can tell
you that but you I certainly can't yeah
I'd be irresponsible of me to tell
people to do something like what I did
because you could get you could get
maimed yeah and in a way it's it's sort
of the shows that I'm most proud of here
are the ones where I was able to
facilitate a little bit of that so it's
sitting down with you it's sitting down
with Lindsey Shepherd who went through
something very similar it's sitting down
with James d'amour these people who did
not ask to be heroes who even if I say
the word hero I can see you're
uncomfortable you know you mean like the
people that didn't want this but somehow
it got thrust upon them and then and
then they got there and then hopefully I
was able to amplify that a little bit
which then spreads that out to all sorts
of other people which is pretty cool so
let's let's I know I don't want to do
this for obviously the entire interview
so let's just say one of us yeah what we
do a bit more so there's one thing that
is and I believe there's a little caveat
to it if you do it and you do it for the
right reasons in other words you could
do it cynically you could stand up
against one of these things in order to
see if you couldn't get famous or
something people will see through that
right especially the people who've gone
ahead down this road because they know
something about it but if you do it for
the right reasons if you're really
trying to advance the ball to challenge
a bad narrative the people who have gone
through this recognize mm-hmm and you
know it won't feed you but it is very
reassuring to discover other people who
see the corrupt narrative who understand
what happens when you challenge it so
anyway if if you're hungry to meet other
people like that standing up you know
you got to figure out what you're gonna
do to feed yourself but it does put you
in contact with lots of people who are
very worthwhile
yeah it's so interesting because again
after being with Peterson it's like
people say to him you know I want to get
a new job should I just quit my job
tomorrow and it's like you have to
seriously think about what your options
are you may hate your job it doesn't
mean you can leave tomorrow right you
got to think about all of this seriously
and I think that that is the key here so
I'm curious how much of this has shifted
what you think politically because you
do talk about politics now and I know
when I had you in there for the first
time I think I said to you we'll revisit
this question because I thought here's a
guy that's that I come from a very
similar political place as him as a
progressive and all of these things and
now I see you know as you know I
consider myself a classical liberal and
I and I love libertarian ideas obviously
we just did stand-up together last night
in Brea California you and your brother
joined me on stage for the for the
second half and it was mostly a
conservative crowd there were some Trump
people there were some lefties and some
liberals but you know mostly
conservatives and they they love you
guys
and yet you both still identify as
lefties and the whole thing and I wonder
now a year and a half later are you
shocked at that that you are now really
liked by people that perhaps you thought
were your ideological opponents and now
you're sort of on the outs with the
people that you used to be allies with
okay that's that's a good question I get
one every episode I am heartened and
flabbergasted by what I encounter on the
centre-right you know this is not the
Republican Party that I remember from my
youth this is a very different entity
and I think it has a lot of refugees
who've been driven out of other places
and they've grouped their because I
don't know because
because something over there is making
sense tonight well as you said to me the
first time we met debut have PTSD
protocol from the president yeah and I
must say we should we should return to
this but I was very heartened to hear
you bring that up during your episode
with with Ben Shapiro and Eric and and
Jordan you you went through a cool
exercise which I think deserves a place
with steel Manning and your exercise I
think was something like where is some
place that you suspect your own thinking
might be incorrect and you brought up
political PTSD as a place to pay
attention to but let's just say I am
shocked that the centre-right seems to
be you know it has protective custody of
liberty and very speech and science of
all things I mean how the heck did the
centre-right end to end up having
custody of these things which are
traditionally things that the right is
uneasy about and the left has has
defended but nonetheless the people who
value them are where they are I think
they do have something wrong you your
initial question was has this changed my
political view and I think one of the
everybody said it would and you know I I
believe I am being honest with myself
when I say really hasn't changed my view
of what is true politically much if at
all I think because what I believe is
true isn't predicated on anything social
nothing right in other words these are
conclusions that I reached through game
theory and evolutionary thinking and
observation of the political landscape
they're not things you know it wasn't
that I went to a dinner party and had a
good time and fell in with their
political idea right so it's not you
know the fact that I am NOT welcomed in
certain quadrants of the left doesn't
change anything about what's true at all
right it can't so I understand that but
at the same time I mean you can go to
I've done public events with you that
are usually we're usually invited by
libertarian organizations
we've done some mine ran things together
and a couple other things and I think
everything that we've done publicly and
when you've joined River stand up the
crowds all basically seemed to be on the
right as you're saying this sort of new
this new center-right that maybe needs a
better phrase than that cuz center right
sort of need something sexier than that
per se but I mean have you been invited
anywhere by progressives to tell your
story or to get some camaraderie or
empathy or sympathy or kudos or anything
other than guff very occasionally and
only slightly I mean the the asymmetry
is amazing and I must say one of the
most interesting things to me about the
early phase of you know this public part
of my life is that initially there was
just this overwhelming message that came
back at me you are a conservative or no
cousin or something yeah that and
welcome to the dark side I think is what
they usually do say that yeah and then
at the point that the phrase I DW showed
up on the landscape then there was this
point about oh the IDW is a you know
right-wing movement or something like
that and so there's a trajectory there's
there's something we track immediate
effects pretty well as people we can
observe them and detect them there's
often a slower pattern that is harder
for us to see and so just by analogy I
find this is true with healing you know
just physical healing if you do damage
to your knee for example there's a
one-month healing trajectory but there's
also a one-year and a five-year
trajectory and they're much harder to
spot mm-hmm so anyway the the
interesting thing is the challenge of
your on the right or now surely will be
moving to the right you know that was
just an overwhelming message that came
back but the ability to talk back to
that message and say actually no still
on the left actually part of a left you
don't even remember exists and one of my
fears is that all of the stuff that the
left was correct about is not getting
properly credited so to the extent
people have seen this hidden tribes
report that came out maybe a month ago
now that says that there's this vast el
zosky ayah 80 percent in the middle who
do agree on you know the desirability of
a fair society that doesn't burden one
population in order to enrich another
and you know that we basically share
that basically it's only eight percent
actually that buy into this hyper
political correctness and there and the
rest right it's a tiny fringe around the
authoritarian left and it's a tiny
fringe on the you know the white
nationalist right and the rest of us in
the middle know we're not in perfect
agreement we don't agree on the order of
the priorities but we do agree basically
on what a good society would function
like and that a lot of the gains I mean
you know the ability to be gay and out
and function in society without that
being a tremendous obstacle that that's
something that you know the left
deserves credit for racial equality
you know equity is a different beast by
virtue of the new I hesitate to even
call it a definition because it's not a
definition in the standard sense but
equality these are traditional left
values and we were right about mmm-hmm
and so the fact that these things are
now no longer controversial that belongs
in the discussion to the left has been
right about some stuff it's also been
wrong about some stuff and the right has
been right about some stuff and it's
been wrong about some stuff and it is
time for that conversation absolutely
and that's why I don't denigrate what it
was I am upset with what it is and
perhaps guys like you and your brother
and Sam some people that still identify
as left these will be able to do a
reclamation project that I just don't
see anymore I see sort of more that this
thing needs to burn so out of the ashes
of Phoenix can rise that's just maybe a
little bit of a tactical thing but let's
just jump back to an evolutionary
explanation for some of this so I asked
you about why some people can do this
from an evolutionary perspective why
some people are able to step up and some
people aren't what about what's the
evolutionary explanation for why this
let's say 8% very loud but small
people feel the need to purge everyone
is there is there an evolutionary
because that seems it would be almost
counter to evolution you'd want to have
more commonalities with people and bring
in a big tent but what I see them
consistently doing is just getting rid
of everybody who dare you know talk back
to the to the God well you know I I wish
I had known this was going to come up
because I would have looked it up but
there was a there was a put me on the
spot there was a a report that emerged
maybe it was six or eight months ago
that I don't you know I haven't looked
into it and it's not my area of
specialty but it sounded right to me and
what it said was that there is a
particular there's a particular
personality trait authoritarianism that
isn't ideological it doesn't really care
whether it's you know defending fascism
or communism mm-hmm what it wants to do
is boss people around and that
essentially what's confusing to people
is that at the moment these
dyed-in-the-wool authoritarians are
concentrated over on the left and
they're saying stuff that sounds
nominally like leftist stuff but that
you know were the winds to shift and the
authoritarians of the moment to be over
on the right they'd be there and so that
that makes sense to me
and what I would like people yourself
included to consider is that there is
almost no point in engaging those people
right this question of the importance of
Liberty is settled right the 80% of us
in the middle all get the fringe on the
far left and the far right are I don't
want to say safe to ignore because they
can always rise up and become important
as the one on the left is doing however
that's not where the game is the game is
all of the people who can't figure out
how to escape from the stigma and all
that is driving civilization so all of
the people who are falling in line
going on on the authoritarian left those
are the people to reach mm-hmm and what
you raised about you know let's say the
audience last night at the comedy club
and you know this is reliable this was
the second one I did with you is exactly
the same the first time the thing that
is so heartening is you know I can come
into a room and you're right that room
last night must have been 95 percent
right of center yeah and first thing you
tell them is here's a progressive I'm I
tell them I'm a radical right yeah it
doesn't dampen their enthusiasm one bit
in fact it they're thrilled to discover
that things are not so bleak and that
there is somebody on the other side of
this thing who's still talking
reasonably and can hear them and can see
them and doesn't think that they're
racist and out of control and so anyway
you know I know I take a lot of flack
for you know interacting with the right
and I'm not listening to that flag yeah
good it is the best thing we can do is
to engage and you know when you spot the
humanity of the people on the other side
then to the extent that we differ over
something we can talk about it all right
well we could keep going down this
Pandora's box of lunacy related to
everything that you've been through but
let's do let's just catch it up to where
we are now and we can start looking at
the future a little bit so you and your
wife Heather who you reference Heather
hang who's been on the show who's a
brilliant professor as well and and and
has that that brave evolutionary tick
that you have to have you end up
marrying a woman that was going to have
the same evolutionary tick as you that's
pretty good you really want to know the
answer yeah Heather and I we were not
going out but we were friends in high
school and you know there's I don't know
that other others will understand the
the phrase but the one that runs in my
head is somebody goes to high school
with the girl you should marry and it
might be you right hello anyway in my
case you know I don't know how because
you know I was I was a confused kid like
every other kid that age there was
something about her that
seemed so very right and I have to say I
was right about that best decision I
ever made was she ever pissed at you
during this because you sort of thrust
her in the spotlight too and the fact is
both of you left your jobs you got a
five hundred thousand dollar settlement
for two tenured positions which to some
people that's out at $500,000 sounds
like it sounds like a lot of money boat
but you this is your life's work you and
your wife you've since relocated your
family and your two kids so this is this
is massive five hundred grand in the
scheme of that is not a lot but was she
ever bothered or hesitant by what you
were doing cuz she didn't go public
about this until a bit after she was
never pissed not for a minute
she and I were in complete agreement we
saw the same thing unfold at Evergreen
the the nature of our teaching at
Evergreen was kind of interesting in the
sense that we had like a little
undeclared graduate program in
evolutionary biology where we couldn't
award you a master's degree but if you
were interested in evolutionary biology
and many people didn't know they were
but they would take my program and then
I would sort of nudge them over towards
Heather's program so we had students
bouncing back and forth and we had a
community of people that were in our
circle so the basic point is that
creates a an opportunity for every night
at dinner Heather and I would compare
notes what we were seeing at the college
and all these things talk about you know
students you know what the students
blind-spot is what they do particularly
well and as this unfolded Heather and I
saw the identical picture or maybe the
way to say it is the the picture of what
was happening emerged between us as we
discussed it and she was let's put it
this way what put me in the bullseye was
the emails that I wrote and the thing as
I said in faculty meetings I never wrote
an email that Heather didn't look at
first and tell me
it's ready and frankly there were a lot
of emails that I didn't send and if I
made one error I believe I should have
sent everyone right because what they do
is they leave a historical record of
what is taking place so the dissent was
in retrospect very clear as he went back
through the mails
but anyway yeah Heather Heather was in
complete agreement the whole time and I
think the confrontation was less in
keeping with you know her personality
traits than mine but in terms of her
commitment and her belief in what we
were doing it was a team effort there's
a lesson in marriage right there there's
probably many lessons in marriage okay
yeah all right so let's just get to
where you are now you guys have left
Washington neither one of you are
teaching at the moment you're trying to
figure out what your future is I assume
the same with Heather
what is that like number one and number
two I think a lot of people would be
surprised to know that schools have not
thrown offers at you I mean you you have
a seriously great public profile now you
are respected by so many people you have
you have fans and not just students now
you have former students but you have
fans that would love to sign up for
courses that you would be teaching and
all sorts of things or I think most
people would look at this on their face
and think wow what an asset this would
get this guy would be not only
intellectually but PR wise and all that
that's not where we're at it's
absolutely not and it it does say
something and I'm I'm an outsider to
whatever discussions it is that result
in nothing of that sort coming our way
but it is conspicuous so you asked what
it's what it's like you know I'm having
a very unusual experience in life and
you know mine my life was great before
any of this happened it's great now the
lack of security is frightening when I
stare at it you know
and I have two kids and if we didn't we
would be in a different position we
could take risks and we could afford to
go through you know years of austerity
but as it is we have responsibilities
and you know our kids didn't sign up for
this mm-hmm so I mean they would have
are you saying they didn't get that gene
what are you telling me oh no they're
not Bohr but yes yeah it's our
responsibility to protect them and so
you know the whole thing has been
frightening from the point of view of
what it means for the future because
literally I don't know it seems like
things are headed along a path in which
you know the settlement that you
mentioned is a tiny fraction of what we
would have earned over the rest of our
careers incurring a huge amount of it
was burned up paying lawyers and taxes
you know you get all that money in one
chunk so we got about two years of
buffer money from that but it wasn't it
wasn't like we got bought out we we
could have in a state that had punitive
damages we likely could have won
something much more like four million
bucks for the amount of income that we
would have earned over the rest of our
careers and why did you guys not go that
route because I think a lot of people
when they saw the number I remember when
I saw the number I got just saw an
article or something and I was like well
whoa whoa why so low because Washington
is one of eleven states without punitive
damages it's that simple
Oh oh I thought you said that Washington
did have punitive damages oh oh I just
misheard you okay so that that that
caused us to effectively cut our losses
and decide that it there was nothing to
be done we did the best we could with
evergreen and cutting our ties with them
at the point that they made it clear I
mean they they behaved atrociously in
negotiations for one thing they dragged
their heels they wouldn't sit down with
us until we were already back on
contract for the next year
fully assuming that we would be going
back into a classroom but one would it
be like to walk onto a campus that is
you know paying a PR firm to demonize
you right what would that be like and we
would have
but they they insulted us in
negotiations they offered us panic
buttons right as if no panic buttons in
the room literally yeah like as if the
problem was that we were panic yeah you
know rather than that they had you know
they could have at least I offered you a
counter baseball bat wouldn't that have
been nice right some but they didn't and
you know hobbling the police the whole
thing was a fiasco so we cut our losses
we we've moved he moved to Portland
which is wonderful I know that's in some
ways not its reputation but it is a
marvelous place you went to the only
more progressive place it does seem that
we have what you're a glutton for
punishment on to the belly of the beast
but I you know the beauty of Portland
you know there's a beauty and there's a
tragedy there is this equity and
inclusion thing and it seems to go up to
the mayor's office who happens to also
frightening Lee in a parallel to
Evergreen be the police commissioner so
he can stand down the police and and has
done so in some circumstance well that
video from a couple weeks ago with an
tyfa basically running traffic in the
middle of portland i mean it's it's
unfathomable that that's happening in
the streets of a united state city right
right it is they are flirting with the
same i mean it is the same story as
evergreen except this is a major
American city you know to have a college
play games with literal Anarchy is
dangerous enough to have a city doing it
I shudder to think you didn't want to
think about Texas I really on this tour
I got to tell you San Antonio I think
you'd have a field day over there well
but here's the thing the other part of
liberalism is also true in Portland so I
never encounter the antifoam madness
and the mayor and his confusion you know
it's like the mayor of your town you
never never run into it what I do run
into is a clean functional city people
as far as I can tell are very decent to
each other
you know they make provisions for
cyclists to commute around the place so
I think in some sense Portland is it
shows exactly the conflict between the
left's better instincts and its worst
instincts and I hope that it will come
around to the kind of enlightened
progressivism that used to exist rather
than the naive progressivism that seems
to have taken over all right let's shift
all together let's do it let's talk
about the stuff you really know how
about that
ok biology evolutionary biology I
thought this would be an interesting
place to start you just recently did a
talk with Richard Dawkins just in the
last couple weeks as I understand the
video of it should be up online somewhat
soon I am told it will be up within a
couple of weeks ok so hopefully people
will be able to actually watch this
conversation very quickly this event was
put together by Pangburn philosophy
there's been a little tumult around that
and I know you just wanted to quickly
address what's going on there yeah so
Pangburn philosophy is obviously
imploded and that has left people
speculating about what happened and why
some of us like myself continued to
participate with amburn just very
quickly for people that have no idea
they were putting together a lot of the
public events that included well the one
that you moderated with jordan peterson
and sam harris in vancouver also the one
that Douglas Murray moderated which I
think was that in the UK or was that
Australia one in Dublin and one in
London yeah and then a series of other
events like the one that you did with
Dawkins and this this day of reflection
that was supposed to happen on November
17th that we all pulled out of which now
I think you can take it from there sure
so let me just say that I know that
there is a lot of speculation about what
took place why people pulled out of the
New York event why some of us like
myself stayed in and I was in at the
point that it was canceled a couple days
ago and I do hope people will recognize
that there was
nikka meant for those of us like like
myself and like Eric who were looking at
the the Pangburn situation and trying to
figure out what to do which was at the
point that Pangburn canceled the
Auckland event something new emerged so
other events had been cancelled but
there had always been refunds for people
who had bought tickets at the point he
cancelled the Auckland event there was a
lack of refund money which called our
attention the fact that something was
off money that should have been kept
separately for that event so that if it
was cancelled it could have all been
refunded somehow wasn't which we didn't
know and and to be clear you guys and I
think not just you guys hadn't been paid
for some previous things too so it
wasn't just about the people that were
buying the tickets just oh I wasn't
allowed in Auckland it was Sydney yeah
Sydney is where speakers as far as I
know that's where speakers didn't get
paid for the first time and certainly
one of the people who didn't get paid
and still haven't been anyway yeah and
also as a sidebar that's so that is why
I pulled out of the day of reflection
thing in New York I was supposed to host
the whole day but then when I realized
that people hadn't been paid for
previous things and I had heard through
the grapevine that there was some shady
stuff going on I just said you know what
let me just not get involved in this
mess of that right which makes perfect
sense
yeah so I think what I did also makes
perfect sense which is I looked at the
situation and I said well you've got
people who haven't been refunded their
money for Auckland
you've got speakers from Sydney who
haven't been paid and if the New York
event comes apart then it's going to
compound that it's going to create new
ticket holders who haven't been paid and
so my thought was let's have an event
that gives people what they paid for so
that we don't make the damage worse and
I certainly didn't sign up for anything
new after the Auckland event was
cancelled and there was a failure to
repay patrons but my thought was from
the point of view of protecting the fan
base from whatever was going on behind
the scenes at Pangburn the the better
part of valor was
to make the event happen and be
successful rather than create another
Auckland situation so in any case that
you know and I should also point out
that up until so Pangburn gave us a
little bit of warning just a couple days
before he cancelled it he said he was
about to cancel it and Eric and I tried
to save it
in fact Eric who had pulled out of the
event quietly so as not to [ __ ] it he
and I got on the phone with Travis and
we tried to get Travis to agree to hold
the event and to let us rescue it we
offered to work for free yeah we would
have liked to have held the event so
that it wouldn't cause further harm to
people and I don't know why Travis
refused but he did so anyway it got
cancelled and I I just I do want people
to understand that it was not that
anybody was unaware that something was
going on the question was what's best
for the fanbase the movement to the
extent that there is a movement is it
better to have another event canceled
and have more harm I didn't think so
yeah and I know this is all a little
insider baseball for people so I know
you just wanted to get that out so I'm
glad that it is a few of us also we had
discussed possibly doing a free thing
and who knows maybe there will be
something in the future if people end up
getting stiffed on ticket prices cuz
obviously we want people to get
something and if we can all figure it
out we will okay so that being said you
did do an event with Richard Dawkins as
we said the video should be up soon
enough Chicago what should we expect
from this and I think on its face I
think a lot of people would say wait a
minute well we've got Weinstein and
Dawkins these guys should agree on
everything
shouldn't they well this goes back to
the question of what happened to
evolutionary biology 30 years ago and
Dawkins and I do agree on a tremendous
amount but the place at which we start
disagreeing I think is the branching
point where you have
the way evolutionary theory went 30
years ago and the way it should have
gone and you know that's not an
indictment in of itself fields take
wrong turns all the time but what should
happen is you should detect that you're
on the wrong path because suddenly
progress ceases and that didn't happen
so so what actually happened 30 years
ago that God well that ironically I
would argue that the the last piece of
progress that we all really agree now
there's been lots of empirical work but
the last piece of theoretical progress
actually involves Dawkins Selfish Gene
we essentially encapsulates a synthesis
that does lots of things including
brings a proper theory of cultural
evolution online which cultural
evolution is a non-issue for almost all
creatures but for birds and mammals it's
a big deal and for human beings it is
new to the big deal so to the extent
that we did not have a way of discussing
cultural evolution prior to the Selfish
Gene Dawkins introduction of the concept
of memes which have now been trivialized
by you know people putting funny
captions on pictures but the concept of
I think you could argue they've become
the most relevant way of communication
in a bizarre way yes but they become you
know little tidbits so how come little
bites the fact is almost everything
about human beings that is interesting
and special at least touches cultural
evolution if not is entirely housed
there so in order to understand
ourselves we have to get this cultural
evolution things straight and Dawkins
set us I believe on the right path
chapter 11 he introduces the word meme
he introduces the concept he sets us in
motion but he makes an error in that
chapter no big deal we all make errors
but it hasn't been corrected in 30 years
and so so so what is that error the
error is in a Mis portrayal of the
relationship between culture and its
evolutionary units and genes and the way
that they evolve so what Dawkins says in
that chapter is that mean
the units of cultural evolution exist in
a new primeval soup right he says this
is a new kind of evolution it begins at
the point that culture begins to happen
and it is independent of the genes
mm-hmm that cannot be the case it cannot
be the case because the only reason that
you are able to pick up units of
cultural evolution is because you have a
brain that your genes created which is
hospitable to those things which means
that to the extent that your culture
starts wasting the time and the energy
and the resources of your genes the
genes are in a perfect position to shut
it down right so my point to Dawkins on
stage in Chicago was that can't be right
and if you make an adjustment to the
theory that you Dawkins presented in
1976 if you adjust it correctly you
discover that many things that are
paradoxical about cultural evolution are
no longer paradoxical and many things
about human beings are suddenly
tractable so can you give me an example
of that I can give you the ultimate
example I will accept that so the
ultimate example has to do with religion
and things that function like it so if
you think about you know this is the
antithesis of some little picture with a
caption honored right you imagine
Catholicism for example Catholicism is a
set of beliefs that has profound
implications on the way that believers
deploy their efforts their resources the
things that they elevate the things that
they issue all of that so the question
is why right
so Dawkins and I would agree there is no
supernatural explanation necessary to
interpret what is taking place on earth
or anywhere else in the universe you
don't need a supernatural explanation if
you are trying to explain phenomena so
why is it that people who
hold a belief that supernatural forces
are at the heart of human affairs why
are those people so successful
historically that's the question and
Dawkins and I disagree with it
I disagree over it because a he has this
view of what cultural evolution is that
it's independent of genes I say it is
actually much more flexible than genes
but it is subordinate to the the will of
the genes and he also does not subscribe
actually he came around a bit on this on
stage I thought but he also does not
subscribe to a a lineage level
interpretation of selection he is a
traditional kin selection aesthetically
that the individual that the gene and
the individual are the the places that
we must interpret evolution and if you
do that then lots of things are
paradoxical hard to explain may be
intractable if you accept that lineages
evolved that adaptation can apply to the
lineage then you can begin to understand
phenomena like religious traditions as
adaptive properties of a population and
there's tremendous progress to be made
so what happened on stage with Dawkins
was at dinner prior to the event we more
or less agreed that I would lead the
discussion because I had a sense of
where we disagreed and he would react to
it I put together a list of points on
which I was certain that we agreed
points on which I was pretty sure we
disagreed and points on which I wasn't
sure which way to call it which we
didn't get to mmm-hmm but anyway I
started out by pointing out the vast
agreement between the two of us
and asked him about each one and more or
less I had been right about where we
agreed and then I started to go through
the list of places that we disagree and
I thought it was a fascinating
conversation it was definitely closer to
the conversation I hoped we would have
I feared we might have there was a lot
of progress could you could you sense
which way not that this matters in the
grand scheme of things but at us at some
level it does which way the audience was
going not that it not that it is about
who gets more cheers or anything but
what I do find fascinating about these
things and although I didn't attend any
of the live events with Sam and Jordan
you know I've watched some of them and
just sort of noting a little bit of
crowd applause and jeers and pauses and
things I think gives you some extra
taste that maybe for you guys on stage
you can't quite quantify well I mean
first of all I'm a believer in that and
it was one of the most important tools
that I used to use in the classroom you
know figuring out what people heard how
it landed what they don't yet have so
anyway I'm very cognizant of what people
are hearing and I was listening
carefully to to the audience and you
know the thing was set in motion you
know has another new atheist event and
so in some sense I was I was battling
uphill because my basic point was new
atheism is is a cul-de-sac it's it's a
problem in and of itself it's a problem
because at the end at the end of it
there isn't enough is that like the most
simplistic way that I could present it
no I mean let me just put it in a stark
term yeah okay
atheism is defensible but new atheism is
wrong and new atheism is wrong because
yet portrays religious belief as a
defect of mind rather than an adaptation
a non-literal adaptation and so in a
room full of people who you know Dawkins
is a very famous person people
presumably showed up to here yeah
Dawkins almost all of those people have
at least deep sympathies with the ideas
of new atheism and so somebody setting
out to say actually new atheism is an
incorrect instantiation of atheism
because it is effectively ideological
and it accuses
people who have religious faith of being
mentally defective and in fact Dawkins
and I tangled over this you know I said
look you're you've called religion to
mind virus mm-hmm that's an incorrect
interpretation and at first he said well
I don't really mean anything deep by
virus he said it's you know you could
argue that every gene in the genome is
like a virus right and I said well but
what people hear when you say that is
that that they're mentally ill for
believing this and he said well they are
mentally ill right and so you know you
could see the division in his own
thinking right because they're at that
point he's then saying both things at
the same he is saying both things and I
you know I understand his position about
you could interpret each gene as
independence right you know I could
defend that position too but if in order
for there to be an honorable atheism we
have to own up to what all that
religious belief was about and then I
mean and this is the place that I get
into an easier pickle but a pickle with
Peterson as well is the question of if
we acknowledge that religious belief is
adaptive then all of the things that are
true of adaptive phenomena kick in and
the most important one is that adaptive
phenomena are not timeless they are
adaptive relative to a historical time
and place and it may be a very
long-standing time and place but the
point is there is nothing it is purely
magical thinking to imagine that
religious traditions that are thousands
of years old
are the core of the toolkit for moving
forward our existence in 2018 is so
novel that if there's one thing we can
be sure of
it's that our adaptive nature is a poor
match for it
so then can anything be truly timeless
is is that the right question well yeah
yeah but the way you do it is this the
longer standing some truth of some kind
is the closer it gets to being timeless
in other words if we look at things that
are very evolutionarily
standing well those things have
persisted through environments that were
very different from each other so what
that means is that thread still
functions irrespective to an extent of
the context the longer it lasts the more
likely it is to speak to truths that
continue to be relevant but the bitter
pill for modern people with respect to
understanding the degree to which
evolution is the key to seeing ourselves
properly is that we live in
circumstances that are more novel than
almost any creature has ever faced now
you know a creature can you know fish
can flop into a boat and it's suddenly a
novel circumstances and it's dead
minutes right don't tell that to the
dinosaurs and the meteor was coming
right well there you go that was so
novel that you know I mean dinosaurs did
survive that yeah one group the birds
yeah they're still with us and they're
doing great but we are creatures living
in circumstances that are not only novel
at an unprecedented level but are
changing so rapidly that even to the
extent that we can figure out what to do
the world changes out from under us we
have to stop that right that is going to
kill us that if you want to know what
the greatest existential threat to
humanity is it is the rate of change
that we have set in motion which makes
it impossible for us to adapt fast
enough to it it has to be slowed down to
a point that we can catch up is that
impossible though because we already
have that power because I'm with you on
this just from my limited knowledge of
this just from what I do you know from
doing these shows and that people can
watch more you know the amount of
information that you can intake on a
given day the amount of things that you
can share you can speed things up and
listen to them two times as fast you can
clip everything and that we can take all
this information things can be
live-streamed like all of this bang bang
bang bang bang bang bang it's happening
faster we're learning more we know
there's a great thirst for this but can
it be slowed down I mean what what force
could slow down Prague
really wisdom and that that's the that's
the problem is there lies yeah thank you
we are children in this landscape and
children grow up right I mean the key to
raising children properly is to is to
back off the things that protect them
enough that they actually
get burned without being burned so
severely that they're crippled in other
words you have to experience the places
that your notions are naive in order to
become last night we are now in a
situation in which we are behaving in a
childlike fashion in you know in a very
you know in a foundry or something like
that
right we're like children running around
in the foundry there's molten metal that
we need to you know figure out how to
recognize it how not that's all right no
we're just pressing every button going
yeah we're just I got this and buttons
are cool there's power yeah we got to
stop doing that I don't think you know
if I'm to be candid about it I don't
think we are in an unrecoverable
situation I can see the path forward and
it's it's all still plausible as far as
I know but I'm worried that we won't get
there and the reason we won't get there
is that there are lots of things that
have been true that just aren't true
anymore
in other words the people who are in
love with you know a limitless market in
which you can do anything that you can
manage and it's all cool and then at the
point we find out that it isn't cool
we might have to take some action but in
the meantime you know you're free to
explore I'm very sympathetic to this
view as you know well I would be
sympathetic to this view if I didn't
recognize that there was a problem in
which all for example if you look at the
way our economic system is hooked up to
our political system there's a problem
where anytime you set a new force in
motion in the market if that force pays
at a high rate in the short-term but it
costs at a high rate in the long term by
the time you get around to discovering
the costs in the long term it has found
its way into the political system so
that it cannot be reversed you can't
have a system in which you can't reverse
things so this way the simplest way to
frame this would be some sort of crony
capitalism kind of
right well you know we're not we're not
truly free market because we've
politicized a competition basically well
you know I try to look at everything
through an evolutionary lens and to me
politics and economics are just one more
landscape and they're interesting
because it's humans and humans are
especially capable in this regard but
the the natural tendency for a creature
that has found its way into a niche is
to protect its access to that niche and
the way creatures do that is they freeze
other creatures out so there is this
natural pattern I mean I can't not see
it now that I now that I've understood
that it exists is this natural pattern
where the upstarts who succeed the
stories that we know we don't know about
the upstarts that failed mostly but the
upstarts that succeed end up
tremendously powerful and then they go
through this process in which they
become hostile to up starkness and they
become hostile to up starkness for the
most natural of reasons which is that
their well-being depends on shutting
down the process through which they
became successful so this could be like
Facebook buying all their competitors
and things of that nature
it's the let's put it this way there are
obvious versions and then there are
innumerable versions that are cryptic
mm-hmm and we're never going to
understand the whole landscape of ways
in which those who have reached this
level of power that you and I will only
dream about that they will then shut
down the access to others said it's like
there's a I don't even want to call it a
conspiracy because it doesn't have to
have any consciousness to it at all but
there is a tendency for for those who
have succeeded to shut down the
mechanism through which they 6ma but you
can see this with people frequently
remarking on the fact that immigrants
are often not that wildly enthusiastic
about further immigration mmm-hmm why is
that
for obvious reasons you know you're
talking about do people who've just
entered at the bottom of the economic
ladder why
more competition well there actually
there's a tension between what people
should want but you shouldn't imagine
that there's some immigrant nests that
necessarily has you favorable to anybody
else who has that label does this also
sort of explain a little bit of what's
happening in the tech world right now in
terms of it seems that these companies
Twitter Facebook YouTube are potentially
at least using algorithms against their
own audience shadow banning people I
mean that they're basically now turning
against their own people because of
their that whatever they perceive to be
their own protection or long-term health
even though I would probably argue in
those cases that's not really what's
gonna happen Oh
I mean without question this is what's
going on and let's put it this way if
you're at the top if you're in that
strata you have a lot to lose through
anything you can't predict and so there
is a way in which we expect the upstart
who got there through some sort of
radical transformation to be favorable
to out a radical transformation but the
way we should understand it is that once
you've gotten there radical
transformation becomes threatening and
you start see it's a conservative
evolutionary force and you know you can
look at what Twitter is playing with
these days with potentially eliminating
like some follower counts you know at a
breathtaking act of paternalism yeah you
know at best and they're doing it for us
for us right because we shouldn't be so
concerned as paying attention but really
the truth is as much as we all recognize
that there's a problem with you know
tweeting to get trivial likes on the
other hand understanding what your
audience hears what they find favorable
what doesn't ring true to them is the
way you learn it's the way you steer and
so effectively Twitter is playing with
blinding us so that yeah we can say
whatever we want into the void but we
have no idea how it land
there's no paying the back to you base
right and so you know I mean
I don't need to tell you you're a comic
stand in front of the room and you get a
lot better when they laugh yeah better
it's better when they laugh yeah exactly
yeah what should we be thinking you know
what before I get to that so as you know
I was just in in Europe and I did a
bunch of the Scandinavian and Nordic
countries and Sweden was a particularly
interesting case because I know that our
fifth most viewed country for this show
is Sweden which is sort of fascinating
considering how tiny Sweden is so I had
sort of circled that we did two shows in
Sweden I had kind of circled them on the
calendar because I was like something's
going on in Sweden I want to figure out
what it is
now I thought if you would have asked me
before I did the show that first night I
thought it was gonna have a lot to do
with immigration what I realized
although there were a lot of questions
about immigration at the end it had much
more to do with gender and what is
happening to their highly egalitarian
society that have done most of the
things related to gender and true
equality correctly for many many years
and all of our friends on the left
always point to Sweden and Norway and
Finland these countries that I was just
added as the examples of their perfect
societies and they're really struggling
with certain things that you know that
the government's forcing them to have
genderless kindergardens and that the
emasculation of men and the removal of
the father and that they have supposedly
Europe's first feminist government and
all of these things so I thought as long
as I have you here and since gender
seems to be such an endlessly
provocative and also misunderstood topic
what should we do on gender right now
yeah
well beyond you going to Sweden and
figuring out what's going on there
something well what ex-truck me as is
that they've done everything right in
effect in terms of egalitarianism and
they've done it for four decades now
they've done it right and when they got
to the end which is now when they got to
the current day they realize that
despite all of this equality men and
women are still different that women
still care more about people and men
still care more about things so even
though they've been given the exact same
opportunity women are still becoming
nurse
and men are still becoming engineers and
it's like the the social justice
warriors or whatever you want to call
that crew they still don't like the
results of true equality so I think
that's why Sweden's in such a weird
place the average person is like what
we've done it right we did it right
everyone's equal you can do whatever we
want but then the result isn't being
allowed to be accepted does that does
that make some sense oh it makes perfect
sense I'm in fact right I think the the
naive left finds the failure of its
hypothesis absolutely galling and so
they're effectively trying to erase that
failure by hard-coding the solution into
government so I think that's exactly
what's happening in Sweden right now and
it's tragic and with respect to sex and
gender it is so needless right the fact
is the truth of sex and gender is there
are parts of it we don't fully
understand yet but in general actually
we do we pretty much understand how we
got here and the truth is it is
asymmetrical it is complementary the
truth of male and female is a
complementary truth it may be largely
irrelevant in the present in other words
technology has eliminated most of the
basis on which the division of labor
between men and women
initially evolved so I think we have
actually an opportunity here to become
to behave in an enlightened fashion that
the the easiest place to solve this
problem is sex and gender what we should
do is pretty clear and it is not hard to
ground in evolutionary theory because
unlike other places like race for
example we do know what to think with
respect to sex and gender mm-hmm and the
basic outline is this men and women are
different for historical reasons the
basis for that difference and the
utility of that difference has largely
been neutralized by the modern world we
don't need to retain
distinctions but some of those
distinctions are built in at a deeper
level than others
so meaning you could potentially be a
stay-at-home dad and that could be
perfectly fine but that probably for
evolutionary reasons is not going to be
the thing that usually happens right but
here's your be my point we can
democratize access to almost everything
with respect to sex and gender there are
very few places where we actually need
to have some asymmetry and access but
probably you know the firefighter who
comes into the burning building through
the roof to pull you out when you're
panicking you know you don't know what
to do because you've never been in a
fire before on average that should
probably be a guy they're just better
built for it if there's a woman who is
well enough able to do it should you you
know be picky about the firefighter who
plucks you out of the Bronco absolutely
not I mean you know I personally am
thrilled to see it every time it runs
against the narrative that we expect
right you know I I'm very fond of Stacy
Brown the the police chief had evergreen
who was driven out along with Heather
and me I thought it was great that she
was a female and that you know she was a
an excellent cop
so I'm up for the narrative being broken
by by by reality as often as possible
but you democratize the access but you
don't force people to do what they
otherwise would for one thing you
wouldn't even want to force it because
for every job that you would you know
force women into at some higher rate
let's say engineering jobs because it
sounds like a good thing to do there's
some awful job that men are
disproportionately represented in that
you would also have to force them to be
fair so you democratize the access you
recognize that the division of labor
that we have that we have inherited is
largely outdated but you don't override
people's choice you know if if women if
you democratize access to engineering
perfectly and women go into it at equal
rates great
if they don't that's cool too so in any
case it's it's a question of allowing
Liberty to decide where people go after
you've done away with unnecessary
barriers well it's so interesting
because I think then you hit it right on
the head that well Sweden's now
politicizing it they're making a point
of making this political because they
will not accept the science of what
they've done correctly and I think that
that is what is what has led the sort of
average person there to go this is this
is just not right
so it's I don't know what the way out
it's I mean I sense that most of the
people there didn't know what the way
out was well I mean the way out really
is to recognize that the the ire of the
authoritarian left on this point is
actually indicative of the whole problem
in other words because sex and gender is
more or less clear the desire to erase
it irrespective of the collateral damage
is an indicator of just how wrong this
path is so you know I find this all the
time where people have if you're not
focused on biology and you're focused on
the world that you find and you're
called by by inequality then you think
well let's just solve the inequality
which is hard-code the solution but then
you hard-code the solution and it says
men and women are the same to the extent
that there's any difference in what they
choose to do that's the result of either
cryptic barriers or internalized
misogyny or whatever right and then the
problem is you're now interfering with
my biology Club right you're now telling
me that we that the received wisdom is
that men and women are the same thing
when I know damn well that can't be
right
so you don't want to build a solution
that forces you to confront your
biologists your physicists your
statisticians right you want all of
these stories to the extent that they're
true have to reconcile all true stories
reconcile to the extent that you've got
a naive notion over here and you want to
just write it in because it seems very
important to you and you're willing to
tolerate all of the Cascade
effects elsewhere you don't belong in a
position of power unfortunately though a
lot of those people are in a position of
power and I think we're seeing more of
them get into positions of power and I
think it's also how now having a counter
effect in Europe which is why we're
seeing the rise of more far-right
parties because people are just like
screw this this is so wrong I'm gonna
take my chances over here
people who inherently are not safe
far-right or certainly not racist are
now playing with people that perhaps
they wouldn't have played with before
because they're so sick of this and I
and I'm worried where that leads us oh I
think I think this is exactly I've heard
you say this is that you are afraid that
the the lunacy over on the authoritarian
left is actually going to you know its
collapse is going to leave people who
otherwise wouldn't play ball with the
far-right yeah over there and not
because they're racist that's the key to
this it's not to tell suddenly become
wake up and be racist or hate women or
aid gays but it will be such a disgust
of reality and a rejection of what's
provable that they're gonna be like at
least there's something over here I mean
it's it's an awful bargain but I think
it is I think I just think it is I see
this frequently where people you know
because they detect that there's
something wrong with communism and
socialism are often driven right pretty
far into the let's not regulate anything
camp and the answer is actually we have
to regulate stuff just out of desire to
continue as a species so you know I
don't want to see people driven because
there's something wrong over here I
don't want people to be driven into into
a reactionary position that is not
justified the thing on sex and gender
though is maybe this is the key question
every reasonable person who just simply
observes the world knows that men and
women are not the same thing they know
that those differences have an
implication for the way we view all
sorts of things like mating and dating
what careers we want to have how we view
risk and all of these things for
historical reasons all reasonable people
can infer that from just their own
observations of
world you are now confronted with people
who insist that you not acknowledge what
you can see mm-hmm
those people are crazy right they're
dangerously out of control
they are dangerously out of control on
other topics where it's harder to know
what's true mm-hmm
but you wouldn't want people who were so
naive as to argue that men and women are
effectively identical but for oppression
in charge of any policy they don't want
them in charge of economic policy in
charge of you know prisons anything so
having seen just how far their confusion
goes can we all agree to shut them out
of the discussion about how power is to
be wielded it and the rest of us can
have a discussion about what our values
are what we think we know what we don't
yet know and what its implications are
that that's the place we should go that
seems like an effective ending here
unless you want to throw in one more did
we not hit something that's been
rattling around in your brain actually
no I covered a lot of territory here
yeah all right well it's always a
pleasure sitting down yeah and you
joined me last night for stand-up in
Brea California this will be up already
but you're joining me tonight in Oxnard
I'm turning into a stand-up comic which
is a biologist worst nightmare no no
it's it's not quite the thing where
you're the lead singer of your favorite
band has laryngitis yeah but it's about
as close as I could hope to come yeah
all right well we're gonna do this we'll
do well we did it about a year ago after
the original one but we'll do this more
than once a year because you're you're
right in the center of all the things
that I think are are right at the moment
and for more on Brett follow him on
Twitter as long as they can track how
many followers he as at Brett Weinstein
you
[Music]